The pipeline function
The pipeline function is the most
high-level API of the Transformers library.
It regroups together all the steps to go from
raw texts to usable predictions. The model used
is at the core of a pipeline, but the pipeline
also include all the necessary pre-processing
(since the model does not
expect texts, but numbers)
as well as some post-processing to make
the output of the model human-readable.
Let's look at a first example with the
sentiment analysis pipeline. This pipeline
performs text classification on a given input,
and determines if it's positive or negative.
Here, it attributed the positive label on
the given text, with a confidence of 95%.
You can pass multiple texts to the
same pipeline, which will be processed
and passed through the model together, as a
batch. The output is a list of individual results,
in the same order as the input texts. Here, we
find the same label and score for the first text,
and the second text is judged
negative with a confidence of 99.99%
The zero-shot classification pipeline is a
more general text-classification pipeline:
it allows you to provide the labels you
want. Here we want to classify our input
text along the labels "education", "politics" and
"business". The pipeline successfully recognizes
it's more about education than the
other labels, with a confidence of 84%.
Moving on to other tasks, the text generation
pipeline will auto-complete a given prompt.
The output is generated with a bit of randomness,
so it changes each time you call the
generator object on a given prompt.
Up until now, we have used the pipeline API
with the default model associated to each task,
but you can use it with any model that has
been pretrained or fine-tuned on this task.
Going on the model hub
(http://hugginface.co/models),
you can filter the available models
by task. The default model used in our
previous example was gpt2, but there are many
more models available, and not just in English!
Let's go back to the text generation pipeline and
load it with another model, distilgpt2. This is
a lighter version of gpt2 created by the Hugging
Face team. When applying the pipeline to a given
prompt, we can specify several arguments, such as
the maximum length of the generated texts, or the
number of sentences we want to return (since
there is some randomness in the generation).
Generating text by guessing the next word in a
sentence was the pretraining objective of GPT-2,
the fill mask pipeline is the
pretraining objective of BERT,
which is to guess the value of masked word. In
this case, we ask the two most likely values for
the missing words (according to the model) and get
mathematical or computational as possible answers.
Another task Transformers model can perform
is to classify each word in the sentence
instead of the sentence as a whole. One example
of this is Named Entity Recognition, which is the
task of identifying entities, such as persons,
organizations or locations in a sentence. Here,
the model correctly finds the person (Sylvain),
the organization (Hugging Face) as well as
the location (Brooklyn) inside the input text.
The grouped_entities=True argument used
is to make the pipeline group together
the different words linked to the same
entity (such as Hugging and Face here).
Another task available with the pipeline
API is extractive question answering.
Providing a context and a question, the
model will identify the span of text in
the context containing the answer to the question.
Getting short summaries of very long articles is
also something the Transformers library can
help with, with the summarization pipeline.
Finally, the last task supported by the
pipeline API is translation. Here we use
a French/English model found on the model hub
to get the English version of our input text.
Here is a brief summary of all the
tasks we looked into in this video.
Try then out through the inference
widgets in the model hub!